all right
what are you doing dude
I think we got to start the show man
wait did you ever even go to Vegas no
dude I just stayed here you were here
the whole time yeah for how long sorry
excuse me
I don't know like three days or
something
who was paying you oh you know we got
the whole head staff and you had the
staff
stay here while you gambled on our fake
slot machine yeah I said Luke what are
you doing this weekend he's like oh
uh my lizard died I'm like that's out so
you made him pay you to come to work for
three days straight well yeah we gotta
misses lizards people we gotta take a
chunk out of somebody's salary to give
me my you know I guess yeah that's true
no real talk I lost a thousand dollars
this weekend and did you really yeah I
actually lost a thousand dollars this
weekend yeah well at least it wasn't
your lizard yeah right Luke